[Music]
once again doctors and nurses are facing
burnout as hospitals fill up
with yet another wave of covet 19
patients driven by the delta variant
mississippi is experiencing one of the
worst outbreaks in the country
just 34 percent of people there are
fully vaccinated and this month
hospitalizations are up more than 450
percent
omar via franca visited saint dominic
memorial hospital in jackson mississippi
where health care workers say they are
worn out and frustrated
but still powering ahead for their
patients
the worry really never goes away wendy
guys leads the nurses in the icu at
saint dominic's in jackson
she's been through coveted surges before
but this one
with the delta variant is leaving
everyone exhausted
what do you worry about with your crew
this go around i'm very concerned about
ptsd
i'm worried about burnout i'm worried
about them questioning their choices of
going into health care
the worry is mixed with grief earlier in
the pandemic
her team lost a colleague in the same
coveted unit where they all worked
what was the emotion in the room when
that was happening there was anger
there was i mean there were tears there
were um
you know there was frustration
frustration at what that we're here that
we're actually having to work on one of
our health care
you know team members dr reginald martin
is a surgeon here
but last year he was a patient fighting
for his life
two weeks before my hospitalization i
rode a bike 75 miles
two weeks after my infection i couldn't
walk to the bathroom without getting
short of breath how do you
tell people out there you don't want
this
what do you tell them i just blatantly
remember
is being in that hospital room with my
o2 saturations in the 80s
being unable to breathe or take a deep
breath you know i'll relay that story to
every patient that
comes in and tell them you know that you
you got to get this vaccine
but like so many he feels frustrated
that not everyone is using the tools
available to them
it's incredibly frustrating to know that
you could have done something
different that you are potentially a
threat to my health
that's frightening despite the
frustration the care
continues dr barack maholtra admits
so does the heartache what would happen
to you
if you were actually to stop and slow
down and hear
each individual patient's story do you
think you could handle
it no i don't think so because then
there will be like so much
like you know helplessness i will be
seeing in them
and there will be nothing i can do for
it but one memory haunts him
a woman dying in his covet ward writing
down
four pages of her final wishes for her
son
did you have to give those last wishes
to her child or did she
i did did she make it no
for cbs this morning omar villafranca
jackson mississippi imagine how
frustrating it is for the medical
community to see people dying when all
the experts say
this could be prevented nobody has to
die anymore
if you get the vaccine nobody has to
have has to go this way we have the
weapon to stop this yeah
and people are choosing not to use it so
much focus too on those who've died but
also
you think of the after facts the effects
rather
thousands of people who are still
struggling with breathing and as he
talked about not being able to ride his
bike yeah what's got me freaked out
again even though we're all vaccinated i
now
start smelling the vicks vaporub again
every morning oh good i can still smell
it good exactly
taking my temperature now all the time
because now i'm just nervous all
of the time yeah doesn't have to be this
way america